In the last lecture we
completed the design
of the Beta, our
reduced-instruction-set
computer.
The simple organization
of the Beta ISA
meant that there was
a lot commonality
in the circuity needed to
implement the instructions.
The final design has a
few main building blocks
with MUX steering
logic to select
input values as appropriate.
If we were to count MOSFETs and
think about propagation delays,
we’d quickly determine that our
3-port main memory (shown here
as the two yellow components)
was the most costly component
both in terms of space and
percentage of the cycle time
required by the memory accesses.
So in many ways, we really
have a “memory machine” instead
of a “computing machine”.
The execution of
every instruction
starts by fetching the
instruction from main memory.
And ultimately all the
data processed by the CPU
is loaded from or
stored to main memory.
A very few frequently-used
variable values can be kept
in the CPU’s register file,
but most interesting programs
manipulate *much* more data
than can be accommodated
by the storage available as
part of the CPU datapath.
In fact, the performance of
most modern computers is limited
by the bandwidth,
i.e., bytes/second,
of the connection between
the CPU and main memory,
the so-called
“memory bottleneck”.
The goal of this
lecture is to understand
the nature of the bottleneck and
to see if there architectural
improvements we might make
to minimize the problem as
much as possible.
We have a number of memory
technologies at our disposal,
varying widely in their
capacity, latency, bandwidth,
energy efficiency
and their cost.
Not surprisingly,
we find that each
is useful for
different applications
in our overall
system architecture.
Our registers are built
from sequential logic
and provide very low
latency access (20ps or so)
to at most a few
thousands of bits of data.
Static and dynamic memories,
which we’ll discuss further
in the coming slides, offer
larger capacities at the cost
of longer access latencies.
Static random-access
memories (SRAMs)
are designed to
provide low latencies
(a few nanoseconds at most) to
many thousands of locations.
Already we see that more
locations means longer access
latencies — this is a
fundamental size vs.
performance tradeoff of our
current memory architectures.
The tradeoff comes about because
increasing the number of bits
will increase the area needed
for the memory circuitry, which
will in turn lead to longer
signal lines and slower circuit
performance due to
increased capacitive loads.
Dynamic random-access
memories (DRAMs)
are optimized for
capacity and low cost,
sacrificing access latency.
As we’ll see in this lecture,
we’ll use both SRAMs and DRAMs
to build a hybrid memory
hierarchy that provides low
average latency and high
capacity — an attempt to get
the best of both worlds!
Notice that the word “average”
has snuck into the performance
claims.
This means that we’ll be relying
on statistical properties
of memory accesses to achieve
our goals of low latency
and high capacity.
In the worst case, we’ll still
be stuck with the capacity
limitations of SRAMs and
the long latencies of DRAMs,
but we’ll work hard to ensure
that the worst case occurs
infrequently!
Flash memory and
hard-disk drives
provide non-volatile storage.
“Non-volatile” means that the
memory contents are preserved
even when the power
is turned off.
Hard disks are at the bottom
of the memory hierarchy,
providing massive amounts
of long-term storage
for very little cost.
Flash memories, with a 100-fold
improvement in access latency,
are often used in concert with
hard-disk drives in the same
way that SRAMs are used in
concert with DRAMs, i.e.,
to provide a hybrid system for
non-volatile storage that has
improved latency
*and* high capacity.
Let’s learn a bit more about
each of these four memory
technologies, then we’ll
return to the job of building
our memory system.